[Musik]
ein Volk begehrt auf gegen den Schleier
gegen ein diktatorisches Regime ein
Regime das menschenhin richtet foltert
vergewaltigt
Bilder aus Iran gibt es kaum nun unter
Lebensgefahr bringen Videos und
Informationen nach außen
daher wollen wir wissen wo das Herz der
Iraner im Ausland schlägt
wir treffen Irans auslandsopposition und
zeigen wie Sie die Proteste unterstützt
und Bilder der mutigen Menschen
verbreitet die sich gegen das mularegime
stellen
[Musik]
wir sind in Santa Monica bei Los Angeles
in Kalifornien lebt die weltweit größte
iranische Community außerhalb Irans hier
treffen wir die Ikone der iranischen
auslands-opposition massiv
die regimekritikerin kommt in Begleitung
eines Bodyguards den sie gilt als Irans
Staatsfeind Nummer 1 auch wir werden vom
FBI überprüft bevor wir sie treffen ist
wütend über die Brutalität des Regimes
es bricht mir das Herz wenn ich sehe
dass sie im 21 Jahrhundert Kinder töten
es bricht mir das Herz wenn ich höre
dass sie auf ihre Augen schießen den
Mädchen in die Brüste
liegen weil dieses Regime Angst hat vor
seinem Volk daher vergewaltigen sie in
ihren Gefängnissen junge Mädchen und
junge Männer
oder sie tun ihn Sachen an die sie dazu
bringen Selbstmord zu begehen dieses
Regime ist wieder sogenannte islamische
Staat das sind Kinder und Frauenmörder
eine unfassbare Grausamkeit die die
46-Jährige beschreibt sie ist zum
Sprachrohr der Opposition im Ausland
geworden es ist auch ihre
Internetkampagne die diese Revolution in
Gang bringt
Massi ermutigt seit 2014 Frauen ihre
Kopftücher abzulegen und sich dabei zu
filmen der anfangssturme Protest ist
inzwischen zu einer Revolution geworden
auch ihr Verdienst
der Kopftuchzwang ist wie die Berliner
Mauer wenn man sie einreißt dann bleibt
nichts mehr vom Regime übrig
das Fundament des Regimes bröckelt Stein
für Stein selbst der führer-
seiner Säulen das kopftuchgebot fällt
fällt auch das Regime
deswegen haben sie Angst und wollen die
Menschen mit Hinrichtungen einschüchtern
lass sie die New York lebt nimmt uns mit
zur iranischen Community nach Beverly
Hills sie ist als Rednerin zu iranisch
amerikanischen Frauenkonferenz
eingeladen wir tauchen ein in eine Welt
reicher Exil Iraner die sich nach der
Revolution hier ein neues Leben
aufgebaut haben
Anwälte intellektuelle weit weg vom
Leben im Land der Mullahs im Iran sie
wollen ihre Solidarität mit den
Protesten zeigen und Massi und die
Oppositionsbewegung finanziell
unterstützen
die Menschen kämpfen mit leeren Händen
gegen einen wild gewordenes
diktatorisches Regime ohne unsere
Unterstützung aus dem Ausland schaffen
sie es nicht ihnen macht das Mut ohne
die Hilfe der auslands-opposition wird
es noch mehr Tote in Iran geben
schafft es unterschiedliche Gruppen von
Oppositionellen zu vereinen
wir hoffen dass unsere Stimmen die
Mächtigen dieser Welt erreichen und sie
helfen können die Frauen in Iran zum
Sieg ihrer Revolution zu führen
unzählige Auftritte wie diesen hat Massi
Aline Georg schon hinter sich gebracht
die Stimmung ist elektrisierend im Kampf
gegen die Molas
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am Rande der Konferenz treffen wir auch
die Deutsch-Iranerin macht sie hat mit
ihrer Familie lange in Deutschland
gelebt ihr Vater Jam sheet ein Deutsch
iranischer Staatsbürger wurde 2020 in
Dubai gekidnappt und nach Teheran
entführt dort steht er jetzt vor Gericht
ohne fairen Prozess ohne Chance sich zu
verteidigen er soll gefoltert und im
Staatsfernsehen zu einem Geständnis
gezwungen worden sein
der mit seinem oppositionssender in
Kalifornien das regimeteran bekämpfte
einen Anschlag auf eine Moschee mit
mehreren Toten vor
Aktivisten die seit 43 Jahren für genau
diesen Moment gekämpft haben wie mein
Vater alle sind jetzt in derselben
Gefahr mein Vater ist dort er hat die
wahrscheinlich bekommt er die
Todesstrafe damit drohen sie ihm seit
zwei Jahren sie haben ihn entführt sie
haben ihn versucht mehrere Male in
Amerika durch ein Attentat umzubringen
was sie jetzt mit ihm machen wissen wir
nicht weil wir keine keinen Zugang zu
ihm haben weil wir kein Information über
ihn haben so geht es auch den ganzen
Menschen im Iran wir wissen nicht wo
ihre Kinder sind die wissen nicht was
ihnen passiert wo sie sind und Sie
bekommen im Nachhinein mit dass sie
hingerichtet worden sind dafür müssen
wir das machen dafür müssen jetzt
einstehen die Lage ist kritisch und wir
müssen mit aller Kraft dahinter stehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Solidarität mit den Protesten in Iran
auch in Frankreich viele Oppositionelle
leben seit dem Sturz des Schah 1979 hier
ich reise in die französische Hauptstadt
um die ehemalige Kaiserin von Persien zu
treffen
sie gibt mir eines ihrer seltenen
Interviews
spricht die heute 84-Jährige Fahrrad
lieber paravi im deutschen Fernsehen
über die Unruhen in ihrer Heimat
sie steht in täglichen Kontakt mit den
Menschen in Iran erzählt sie uns die
Berichte über Exekutionen und Folter
erschüttern sie zu tiefst
mich
das macht mich krank ich möchte gar
nicht darüber reden
sie vergewaltigen junge Mädchen was sie
jungen Frauen antun sie schießen ihn auf
bestimmte Körperteile man schießt auf
Kinder was hat man mit den Tätern
gemacht das sind unsere Mitbürger was
hat man ihnen in den Kopf gesetzt es ist
so schrecklich aber ich verliere die
Hoffnung nicht dass irgendetwas
passieren wird denn dort geht gerade
eine Revolution los
eine Revolution war es auch der die
frühere Kaiserin von Persien und ihr
Mann selbst einst zum Opfer fielen
1967 wurde Farah Diba zur Kaiserin von
Persien gekrönt
als erste Frau in der Geschichte ihres
Landes
1979 wurden die parallys von den Mulas
aus dem Land gejagt auch unter der
Herrschaft des Schah gab es den brutalen
Geheimdienst zawag und
Menschenrechtsverletzungen viele
sprachen damals von einer Diktatur des
Schah der 1979 ins Exil musste
auch heute fordern die Menschen dort
wieder Freiheit was empfindet die
Kaiserin dabei
es ist schön dass ich noch erleben darf
was in ihrer Hand passiert
trotz aller Schwierigkeiten die ich und
meine Familie damals hatten als wir den
Iran verlassen mussten wie viele Iraner
ich gebe ja zu dass das Land unter uns
damals Probleme und Defizite hatte aber
nicht bis zu diesem Grad dieses
schreckliche Regime heute meine Waffe
war und ist immer positiv zu bleiben und
immer daran zu glauben Licht wird die
Dunkelheit ablösen
die ex-kaiserin hofft eines Tages in
einen freien Iran zurückkehren zu können
am Ende unseres Interviews hat sie noch
eine Botschaft an das Regime in Teheran
don't kill and shoot the young töten sie
nicht die jungen Menschen töten sie
nicht ihre Landsleute schießen sie nicht
auf sie sie sind ihre Brüder und
Schwestern sie sind ihre Kinder in ihre
Kinder müssen mit ihnen in der Zukunft
leben
und denjenigen die sich religiös nennen
sage ich sie haben unserem Land und der
Religion großen Schaden zugefügt
die Menschen werden sie eines Tages aus
dem Weg räumen
nicht aus dem Weg räumen lassen sich
diese gepanzerten Autos die Zentrale des
Fernsehsenders Iran international in
London wir müssen Sicherheitsschleusen
durchlaufen um Chefredakteur damit und
pur zu treffen
keine Revolution ohne Bilder Iran
international ist zu einer der
wichtigsten Quellen für die Bilder und
Videos geworden die trotz Zensur aus
Iran an die Öffentlichkeit kommen rund
um die Uhr wird hier gesendet eine Art
iranische CNN
und sein Team bekommen täglich tausende
Videos aus Iran das macht sie zur
Zielscheibe
auf der Grundlage von Informationen der
Londoner Polizei sind Gruppen
identifiziert worden die konkrete Pläne
hatten unsere Mitarbeiter hier in London
entweder zu töten oder zu kidnappen
bedroht wird auch die erfahrene Iran
Korrespondentin Nici Machu kein Grund
für sie die Arbeit einzustellen im
Gegenteil
international gibt den Menschen nach
Jahrzehnten endlich eine Stimme die
ihnen das Regime mit aller Gewalt
verweigert und sie erhalten von uns
wahre konkrete Informationen die die
Propaganda des Regimes ihnen verweigert
auch mit Drohung
zurück in Los Angeles wir begleiten
Massi Aline Georg ins Persische Viertel
auf der Fahrt erzählt sie uns dass sie
ständig Morddrohungen bekommt und
letztes Jahr fast in den Iran entführt
wurde
dieses Jahr wollte mich jemand
erschießen das FBI hat einen großen Mann
verhaftet der mit einem geladenen Gewehr
vor meinem Haus auftauchte er wollte
mich töten ich gebe den Menschen in Iran
doch nur eine Stimme davor hat das
Regime große Angst
[Musik]
Massi zeigt keine Angst und läuft ohne
Bodyguard über den persischen Platz im
persischen Viertel am Westwood Boulevard
auch Angeles genannt hier gibt es
Restaurants Buchläden Friseure die
meisten solidarisieren sich offen mit
dem Protesten in ihrer Heimat
knapp eine halbe Million Menschen in
Kalifornien haben iranische Wurzeln
wir gehen mit Massi ins Person golfcafe
dort steht an Weihnachtsbaum an jedem
Zweig hängt ein Foto mit einem
Todesopfer der Proteste
Kurkuma das ist ein mörderisches Regime
vor dem niemand in Sicherheit ist
solange es an der Macht ist selbst die
eigenen Leute der Islamischen Republik
nicht selbst der Enge Kreis von promenei
stellt sich doch jetzt gegen diesen
Mörder dieses Regime fängt an von innen
zu verfaulen bis zuletzt glaubten sie
ihre Säulen sind unverwüstlich aber
jetzt haben Würmer die Säulen befallen
und die unumstößlichen Säulen fallen
das
am Strand von Santa Monica erzählt uns
Massi dass sie mehr aufgewachsen ist und
ihre Heimat vermisst dann gibt sie schon
wieder Telefoninterviews für uns hat sie
noch eine spezielle Botschaft übrig
spricht mir das Herz wenn ich sehe dass
Europa und der Westen nur reden reden
die Menschen in Iran rufen ja nicht nur
totträume nee sie handeln auch und gehen
auf die Straßen und sie halten ihre
Herzen und Köpfe hin auf die geschossen
wird
ich bin müde immer nur zu hören dass sie
die Verbrechen verurteilen jetzt ist es
an der Zeit zur Tat zu schreiben
Deutschland zum Beispiel Deutschland
macht Millionengeschäfte mit dem Regime
interagieren es hat seine Tore für ein
islamisches Zentrum geöffnet und für die
Täter dieses Regimes dort warum
Deutschland könnte doch der erste Staat
sein der eine führende Rolle übernimmt
und alle Staaten dazu auffordert diese
fortschrittliche Revolution in Iran
endlich offiziell anzuerkennen
die mutigen Frauen Irans sie sind auf
die Hilfe des Westens angewiesen Massi
Aline Georg und die anderen werden
weiterkämpfen für die Freiheit der
Frauen und für einen freien Iran
[Musik]